if you stop in the engine room would you
ask the Parvati to send Sam down to the
bridge
we are now in orbit above Byzantium
captain captain
I wish to offer my commendations for
convincing the udl gunship to leave hrs
- 1084 I did not favour the idea of
being stripped and sold for parts
you
[Music]
area assessment spick-and-span
you
[Music]
new area discovered preparing to that's
far enough
what are you doing here how did you even
get inside Hagen I've never heard of her
is she from the board dammit I knew this
would happen
that's a gentle womanly way of putting a
captain she's obsessed with aliens this
is utter nonsense I've never even been
to groundbreaker
what happened to the team tell me you
didn't move their suspension tanks
small consolation my team the finest
minds of their generation reduced to
salvage we were trying to prove that the
colony could survive the crisis bearing
down on us
what are you doing doctor this
information is beyond classified you can
write me up in your report it hardly
matters I'm researching a new way to
feed the colony the crops we
transplanted from Earth don't give us
the nutrients we need our colonists
might not realize it you the food we
grow here barely sustains I believe that
I look around I know we would
there are other teams we didn't want I'm
desperate
if I die
the one on the wanted posters I'll do
doctor what choice do I have commit
alien I need to get out of here Phineas
can contact me when he's ready to work
together for now I had better pack up
the lab not so fast captain won't you
just give me one reason
[Music]
you
why was I built to feel ennui
the groundbreaker has approved our
request for docking captain you're free
to distant
[Music]
is it done well damn contract
technically I owe you and next it Adam
you think mate
[Music]
[Applause]